la première journée
achetée ensemble en 2019 on a la visité
moi je pense 3 ans plus tard Valérie
veut déménager en banlieue pour plus
grand pour sa famille sa sœur est
contrainte elle aussi de le faire
incapable de racheter sa part ces deux
auto je pense que si les touilles avait
été moins élevés on aurait peut-être se
le permettre mais là les taux Harry
Potter à cause beaucoup d'incertitudes
puis beaucoup de questionnements
beaucoup de stress on n'est pas capable
en fait prévoir à quoi vont ressembler
nos paiements d'hypothèque un mâle
nécessaire selon le gouverneur de la
Banque du Canada TIFF meclean il y a pas
manières facile de restaurer la
stabilité des prix la Banque du Canada
augmente pour une sixième fois depuis le
début de l'année sont tout directeur il
atteint maintenant
3,75%, mais va-t-elle trop vite c'est
mon inquiétude un peu ça s'est fait
tellement rapidement cette fois-ci on
voit l'impact déjà on voit l'impact sur
le marché de l'immobilier à Toronto
avant couvert et au Québec les prix ont
reculé les ventes aussi on sent que
moins de frénésie j'ai pas encore déco
de gens qui regrettent
pas forcément c'est plus difficile pour
les acheteurs de se qualifier pour
accéder à la propriété dans les
dernières semaines je vous dirai deux
trois semaines on commence vraiment
sentir que il y a certains ménages
certaines familles qui commencent à été
soufflé par leur versement
mille dollars à tout variable la hausse
de 50 points de base de ce matin
représente une augmentation des
mensualités de 110 dollars depuis mars
ça représente une hausse cumulative de
710 dollars c'est très anxiogène le
stress des sœurs pieuses est aussi monté
d'un cran c'est la réalité parce que oui
le taux directeur augmente mais il y a
aussi tout ce qui va autour qui augmente
donc ça fait en sorte que tes épicerie
le gaz tout d'autres choix déchirés en
vue alors que d'autres hausses sont
aussi prévues d'ici la fin de l'année
ici jacauderie Charbonneau Radio-Canada
Montréal